Marvel Studios is really going through a
lot of changes right now changes that we
are going to start to see this new year
in 2024 some they are voluntarily doing
because they think it's what is going to
be best for Marvel Studios and the
future of the MCU and some are
unfortunately placed upon them like the
Jonathan major recasting and the writer
strikes and actor strikes that delayed
projects but both of these situations
are causing Marvel Studios to have to
make some pretty big changes to a lot of
key aspects of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe moving forward and today we're
going to talk about two of the biggest
changes that Marvel Studios has to make
that some fans are excited for and some
fans are really not excited for one is
the recasting of century in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe many of you might
have heard this yesterday but Steven
young young is no longer going to play
Century in the Marvel Cinematic
universe's movie The Thunderbolts now
this comes as bad news to some but good
news to others because he didn't exactly
look the role of century now don't get
me wrong he could definitely buff up and
they could definitely give him a long
blonde wig however some fans were pretty
disappointed in this casting I was
looking forward to it but unfortunately
it looks like Steven young is the one to
have dropped out himself but the big
question that everybody is asking right
now is was centry a really big part of
the Thunderbolts or was he sort of just
a side character and was he going to pop
up later on in the future of the MCU
well we're going to break all of that
down today in this video as well as go
over some Kang casting announcements
most of you know Jonathan Majors is out
in Marvel Studios right now is looking
to cast a new Kang the Conqueror but
before we dive in be sure to like this
video And subscribe if you subscribe and
leave a comment you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items and some DC items as well
the winner gets to pick one item and we
pick one winner at the end of each month
also big congratulations to YouTube user
at
AVR
0709 for being the winner of the
December giveaway and again we're still
doing giveaways each month this year so
The Hollywood Reporter was the first
Outlet to report that Steven young young
will not star in Marvel's Thunderbolts
they said like many temples across
Hollywood it was delayed amid the Dual
writers and actor strikes and they did
not state the actual reason for Steven
young not being able to appear in the
Thunderbolts movie but they did say the
strikes put schedules and disarray all
across Hollywood simply implying that
since the movie got delayed he can no
longer do it anymore it was delayed over
a year and this really threw his
schedule off they also note that Marvel
Studios has never officially announced
the casting of century which is true now
the major outlets and major insiders did
report this and it was basically all but
confirmed by Marvel Studios and in fact
we know a decent amount of plot details
about Century being involved in the
Thunderbolts and yes he was going to be
a pretty significant character and in
fact it sounded like he was going to be
somewhat the main Villain at the end of
it all if you're familiar with Robert
Reynolds AKA a century you know that
it's not just Century but there is
something that comes along with him and
that is the void and according to
previous reports that we heard the void
and century were kind of going to be
what were going up against the
thunderbolts at the end or I guess I
should say the Thunderbolts were the
ones going up against the void and
centry at the end some have even said
this is kind of the suicide mission that
the Thunderbolts were going to be sent
on to go up against century and the void
now what's interesting is with this news
that Steven young young will not star in
Marvel Thunderbolts anymore is the fact
that Marvel Studios has very recently
met with Ryan goling about playing a
character in the MCU and now a lot of
people are speculating that these two
could possibly be linked just because we
are finding out now that Steven Yan is
not going to play Century doesn't mean
that Marvel Studios just recently made
the decision they could have made this
decision a while ago and that could be
why they met with Ryan golin because
they knew that they needed a new person
to play centy in the MCU for the
Thunderbolts film now of course keep in
mind that Marvel Studios usually meets
with actors about multiple different
roles so for those who want him to play
Ghost Rider or Nova that is entirely
still possible but you have to admit
Ryan goling if you throw a long blonde
wig on him could look the part and very
well we already know he can get jacked
for the role in fact he's still pretty
jacked from filming Barbie and we know
that he can play sort of a rugged role
based off of other movies we've seen him
in so as far as casting choic are
concerned I think Ryan goling is
actually a pretty good choice and yes
based off of everything that we know
they still do plan to have Century be a
part of the Thunderbolts film because he
was going to be a pretty big character
in the movie again it sounded like he
was going to be one of the major threats
of the film if he wasn't going to be the
main villain from what we knew he was
going to start off good and maybe start
off as even a member of the Thunderbolts
team but due to the void and his mental
conditions he sort of doesn't have
control anymore and can't be controlled
which of course you know is what
Valentina wants so she sends the
Thunderbolts team to stop him again it
sounds like scheduling was the main
problem here not like Marvel Studios
decided to scrap the role of century and
again the way The Hollywood Reporter
reported it it sounds like Steven young
was the one who dropped out himself so
for those who still want Cy in the MCU
don't worry it sounds like he's still
definitely going to be a really big part
of this movie and we can kind of say the
same now for Kang now I've seen a lot of
mixed comments about this online some
people say yes just recast Kang the
Conqueror some people say step away from
Kang altogether right now I think we're
kind of too deep into the Kang story to
Simply step away they've already shown
us the Council of kings and how many
King variants out there there are I
think recasting would be the best bet
here and as you might have heard Marvel
Studios has already begun the recasting
process which is a pretty decent
indicator that they do plan on having
King the Conqueror back in the MCU maybe
not incredibly far from now we do know
that Marvel Studios kind of wants to lay
low for for a little bit and kind of
have Kang just in the background because
if you hear Kang you automatically think
Jonathan majors and they don't want that
negative connotation associated with
King right now so they might give it
some time but they are right now looking
to recast especially with upcoming films
like Avengers 5 and Doctor Strange 3
which we know is going to be a
multiversal film they're going to have
to at least mention Kang in these films
because he still is the overall looming
threat to the Multiverse right now and
according to Daniel rpk Coleman Domingo
is reportedly one of the actors that is
being considered to replace Jonathan
major as king the Conqueror in the MCU
many people know him from Fear The
Walking Dead The Color Purple Candyman
Euphoria and recently Rustin now he is
older than Jonathan Majors he is 54
years old so this could mean that Marvel
might have a plan of kind of bringing in
a Kang the Conqueror who could be older
wiser stronger than all of the other
ones that we've seen so far most of us
know by now thanks to Insider reports
that the beyonder Kang ver iant is going
to be the main villain of the Multiverse
Saga and Avengers Secret Wars that is if
Marvel decides not to change their
current plans which they very well could
I do like the idea of going for an older
wiser and stronger King the Conqueror
someone who has possibly already
conquered a vast majority of the
Multiverse which the other kings don't
know about so this variant could have
gone on to really Ascend above them all
and become the beyonder because based
off of what we know essentially we're
going to have a villain in the MCU which
we believe right now is the Kang Trio
that the Avengers basically can't defeat
and that makes sense because they
control time they can see every move
just like we saw in Loki season 1 and
Loki season 2 he who remains could
predict everything that Loki and Sylvie
were going to do because he saw it
already so according to Alex P at the
cosmic circus essentially a bigger
villain is going to come in to defeat
them but this bigger and batter and
stronger villain is going to have a
bigger weakness that the Avengers can
exploit to ultimately defeat so Coleman
Domingo is on the list for Marvel
Studios what do you think about that
casting Choice do you like it do you not
and also let me know what you think
about Ryan Gosling possibly playing
Century in the MCU let me know your
thoughts about all this news in the
comments down below and don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest MCU
news you can find us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
woof